here's what would happen if Earth
orbited UI scooty UI scooty is 1700
times larger than the Sun and the
largest star the human race has ever
discovered if Earth was orbiting UI
scooty instead of the sun we would have
to be one and a half trillion kilometers
away from it just to keep from burning
to a crisp and say goodbye to your
birthday parties it would take about 10
000 years for Earth to complete just one
orbit around this big star each season
would last 2500 years Earth would now be
sitting in the middle of the Milky Way
where cosmic rays and light from other
stars would shine bright enough that
Earth would never have night again uy
scooty is also 40 times closer to death
than our sun when it dies it's expected
to explode with the force of more than
100 supernovas and will obliterate
everything nearby so